HONOR IS SHAWRCH JOINING US
NOW JEROME CORSI FACING HIS
OWN LEGAL FIGHT WITH THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL AFTER
REJECTING MUELLER'S PLEA
DEAL BECAUSE HE SAYS HE
REFUSES TO LIE UNDER OATH
AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP.
DR. CORSI WAS CRIMINALLY
THREATENED AND COERCED TO A
LIE.
TELLS THE TRUTH.
HERE WITH FURTHER REACTION
AUTHOR OF THE BOOK SILENCE
NO MORE DR. JEROME CORSI.
YOU SPENT 40 HOURS WITH
MUELLER, CORRECT?
>> YES, SEAN, 40 HOURS.
>> YOU ARE 72 YEARS OLD,
RIGHT?
>> YES, I'M 72.
>> Sean: IN THE COURSE OF
ANSWERING QUESTIONS, YOU
DIDN'T REMEMBER EMAILS
SPECIFICALLY FROM TWO YEARS
PRIOR.
>> CORRECT.
>> Sean: AT TIMES YOU
AMENDED SOME OF YOUR
TESTIMONY.
>> ALMOST CONTINUOUSLY AS I
SAID I'M NOT A HUMAN TAPE
RECORDER.
YOU CAN'T PUNCH A BUTTON AND
I CAN'T REMEMBER PRECISELY
CONVERSATIONS OR EMAILS IN
THIS GOTCHA GAME THAT THE
MUELLER PROSECUTORS WERE
DETERMINED TO PLAY.
IT BECAME PSYCHOLOGICALLY
REALLY DISTURBING AND BY THE
END OF 40 HOURS I THINK MY
MIND WAS COMPLETE MUSH.
>> Sean: I CAN'T TELL YOU
WHO WAS ON THE SHOW ON
MONDAY.
I'M WITH YOU.
BUT, WHEN YOU FOUND OUT AND
YOU WENT THROUGH YOUR PAPERS
AND EMAILS AND STUFF, YOU
SAID UH-OH I GOT THAT WRONG.
I AMEND IT.
FIRST YOUR REACTION TO THE
PRE-DAWN RAID OF ROGER STONE
TODAY.
>> I WAS SHOCKED.
THIS IS GESTAPO LIKE
TACTICS.
WHAT'S THE POINT IN HAVING
ALL THESE ARMED POLICE WITH
RIOT GEAR BURSTING INTO A
HOUSE AT 7:00 A.M. WIFE AND
ROGER IN BED.
THIS IS NOT AMERICA.
THIS IS NOT THE WAY WE TREAT
PEOPLE IN AMERICA WHO ARE
BASICALLY TRYING JUST TO BE
POLITICAL OPERATIVES WHO ARE
EARNING A LIVING AND I MEAN,
IT FRIGHTENS ME TO THINK
WHAT THE FBI COULD DO
BURSTING INTO MY HOME WITH
MY WIFE ASLEEP AND THE
FAMILY ASLEEP.
THERE IS NO NEED FOR IT.
AND I THINK INCREASINGLY,
THAT WE'RE SEEING AN
OUT-OF-CONTROL MUELLER
OPERATION THAT IS DETERMINED
TO TERRORIZE PEOPLE AND
CRIMINALIZE POLITICS.
I THINK IT'S VERY
FRIGHTENING FOR THE
DIRECTION OF AMERICA.
>> Sean: DO YOU STILL FEAR
BECAUSE WHEN YOU REFUSED TO
SIGN WHAT YOU SAID WAS A
LIE, WHAT WAS SAID TO YOU
AND YOUR ATTORNEYS AND ARE
YOU AFRAID THAT THEY ARE NOW
GOING TO PRE-DAWN RAID YOU
AND YOUR HOUSE?
>> WELL, IT COULD HAPPEN.
THE ATTORNEYS MY ATTORNEYS
WERE TOLD BY THE MURIEL
GROUP WE WILL TAKE IT FROM
HERE.
VERY ANGRY, ARROGANT AND
THAT'S NOW OF COURSE BEEN
THE END OF NOVEMBER.
AND NOTHING HAS HAPPENED.
I THINK WHEN I READ THIS
INDICTMENT TODAY, IT'S
ABSOLUTELY CLEAR I'M BEING
ACCUSED OF NO WRONG-DOING.
I HAVE DONE NOTHING WRONG,
SEAN.
I BROUGHT IN AND OFFERED ALL
OF MY COMPUTERS.
MY BACKUP SYSTEMS.
MY CELL PHONE, MY EMAILS.
I WENT IN TO COOPERATE.
I HAVE OFFERED TO COOPERATE
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS AND
DID I NOT WILLINGLY AND
KNOWINGLY GIVE INFORMATION I
KNEW TO BE FALSE TO DECEIVE
THE "SPECIAL REPORT."
I HAD A MEMORY PROBLEM.
>> Sean: YOU WERE REFERRED
TO AS PERSON NUMBER ONE IN
ROGER'S INDICTMENT.
THEY GO THROUGH A SERIES OF
EMAILS THAT AND
COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN THE
TWO OF YOU WHO ARE
BASICALLY, YOU KNOW, YOU ARE
SAYING OH, WHAT DOES
WIKILEAKS HAVE NOW AFTER --
THIS IS AFTER DEBBIE
WASSERMAN SCHULTZ, THE FIRST
CLINTON EMAIL DUMP, WHICH WE
NEVER WOULD HAVE GOT BE
PROBABLY IF A LOT OF THESE
THINGS WERE BETTER
PROTECTED.
THAT'S A DIFFERENT ISSUE FOR
A DIFFERENT DAY.
BUT YOU WANT TO FIND OUT,
YOU WORKING FOR WORLD NET
DAILY AT THE TIME.
YOU WANTED TO FIND OUT LIKE
EVERYBODY ELSE IN THE MEDIA
WHAT ELSE DID JULIAN ASSANGE
AND WIKILEAKS HAVE?
WHAT WAS HE GOING TO RELEASE
NEXT?
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT IT.
I KNOW YOU WROTE A
DISSERTATION AT HARVARD DID
YOU NOT ON THE PENTAGON
PAPERS.
>> IN FACT, THAT'S MY PH.D.
DISSERTATION 1927 IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF POLITICAL
SCIENCE.
IT WAS ON THE PENTAGON
PAPERS CASE.
I MEAN I'M THINKING THAT WAS
47 YEARS AGO.
I MEAN, IT WAS AMAZING TO ME
THAT THAT'S WHAT I FOCUSED
ON.
AS A JOURNALIST.
I HAD A RIGHT TO TALK WITH
ASSANGE TO SPEAK WITH
ASSANGE, TO PUBLISH WHAT
ASSANGE HAD.
IT'S JUST THAT I HAD NO
CONTACT WITH ASSANGE.
>> Sean: "NEW YORK TIMES"
PUBLISHED IT.
>> YEAH.
>> Sean: BY THE WAY YOU SAID
TO ME YOU HAVE NEVER TALKED
TO JULIAN ASSANGE.
>> NEVER.
>> Sean: NEITHER HAS ROGER
STONE IF I REMEMBER
CORRECTLY.
>> AS FAR AS I KNOW.
ROGER CAN SPEAK FOR HIMSELF.
I KNOW FOR MYSELF I HAVE
NEVER SPOKEN TO JULIAN
ASSANGE DIRECTLY OR
INDIRECTLY.
NO CONTACT.
>> Sean: SO COMPARING THE
PENTAGON PAPERS CASE, WHICH
YOU DID A DISSERTATION
IRONICALLY ON, AND LOOKING
AT THIS CASE, ALL YOU AND
ROGER WANT TO KNOW WHAT DOES
HE HAVE?
NEITHER ONE OF YOU WERE PART
OF A CONSPIRACY TO STEAL
INFORMATION FROM ANYBODY NOR
DID YOU STEAL ANY
INFORMATION FROM ANYBODY.
THE PRESIDENT 6-3 DECISION
IN THE PENTAGON PAPERS CASE,
THE U.S. AGAINST THE "NEW
YORK TIMES" CLEARLY STATES
THAT THE "TIMES" HAD A RIGHT
TO PUBLISH INFORMATION AS
LONG AS THEY DIDN'T STEAL
IT.
AND YOU WERE REQUESTING
INFORMATION AND TRYING TO
FIND INFORMATION LIKE MANY
OTHERS IN THE MEDIA WHAT WAS
COMING NEXT, CORRECT?
>> YOU ARE EXACTLY RIGHT,
SEAN.
WE HAD A RIGHT TO DO THIS.
EVERY JOURNALIST AND PERSON
INVOLVED IN POLITICAL
OPERATIONS AND THE CAMPAIGN
JULIAN ASSANGE NOT ONLY
DROPPED 40,000 EMAILS DEBBIE
WASSERMAN SCHULTZ JULY 22ND,
2016, WITHIN A DAY OR TWO HE
SAID HE HAD MORE EMAILS TO
COME.
AND, OF COURSE, THE
SPECULATION WAS RAMPANT.
I WANTED TO KNOW.
IRVING WANTED TO KNOW.
I PAUSED ON A COUPLE OF
EMAILS TO TED MALEK TO SEE
ASSANGE.
THERE IS NO CRIME IN ANY OF
THIS.
THIS IS NORMAL POLITICS.
>> Sean: WHY ARE YOU
CONFIDENT?
YOU SEEMED CONFIDENT THE
LAST TIME YOU EVERYWHERE ON
THIS SHOW THAT YOU WERE
GOING TO GET A PRE-DAWN
RAID.
YOU FEEL IT'S LESS LIKELY
TODAY, WHY?
>> MUCH LESS LIKELY.
I THINK I HAVE PUSHED BACK.
I HAVE WRITTEN THIS BOOK
SILENT NO MORE.
THE INDICTMENT SUGGESTS
NOTHING I HAVE DONE IS
WRONG.
I BELIEVE I HAVE DONE
NOTHING WRONG.
>> Sean: IF IT DOES HAPPEN?
>> IF IT DOES HAPPEN WE WILL
DEAL WITH IT MY FAMILY IS
PREPARED.
IT MASS MADE MY LIFE, MY
FAMILY'S LIFE, MY WIFE A
NIGHTMARE.
CAN'T SLEEP.
UP DAYS, BAD DAYS.
THIS IS NOT AMERICA.
I HAVE DONE NOTHING WRONG.
I WAS A JOURNALIST.
I WENT IN AND DID THE BEST
OF MY ABILITY WITH FAULTY
MEMORY.
I CAN BE CONVICTED OF HAVING
A BAD MEMORY BUT I CAN'T BE
CONVICTED OF TELLING THE
SPAWN OR THE FBI SOMETHING I
KNEW TO BE FALSE TO DECEIVE
THEM.
IT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
WE WILL WATCH CAREFULLY.
THIS IS SCARY.
YOU KNOW, IF HILLARY CLINTON
CAN DELETE 33,000 SUBPOENAED
EMAILS, ACID WASH HER HARD
DRIVE AND BUST UP DEVICES,
NOTHING HAPPENS?
ALL THESE OTHER PEOPLE, HIGH